haben häuser wie mit fahnen dekorierte
nummer denkt man wäre ein paar
jahrzehnte zurück und das erschreckt und
werden wir im stadtrat zum beispiel auch
den antrag gestellt dass das fazit
coffee tea unter denkmalschutz gestellt
werden sollte die dürfen auch nicht mehr
werden und da muss immer der widerspruch
er permanent der widerspruch
[Musik]
die laufen rum die skandieren die haben
häuser die mit fahnen dekorierten nummer
denkt man wäre ein paar jahrzehnte
zurück und das erschreckt als
auffangbecken fungiert die partei die
rechte insofern unterscheidet sie sich
von anderen parteien im rechten spektrum
durch eine größere radikalität durch
eine klare bezugnahme zum
nationalsozialismus durch einen klaren
antisemitismus
aus der luft betrachtet wird dortmund
dorstfeld wie ein bürgerlicher stadtteil
doch das viertel mitten im ruhrgebiet
ist inzwischen zu einer art pilgerstätte
für neonazis geworden
regelmäßig treffen sich an der
emscherstraße führende rechtsradikale
organisieren von hier aus ihre
aufmärsche gegen ausländer oder den
staat israel auf den hauswänden die
graffitis nazis so beschreibt die rechte
szene ihr viertel selber vorbereitung
für die nächste demo im gepäck jede
menge deutsche reich geht es heute
wieder gegen israel geht es heute wieder
gegen israel
bei der aktion hier brauchen wir gar
nicht sprechen was haben sie denn dann
im prinzip gegen das kann ich jetzt
nicht sagen warum nicht
so feiere meinung
machen sie es gleich dann oder
wir haben nur freier mann
aber sie können ja sagen was sie gegen
den starken haben warum sie dann immer
sagen dass palästina sich noch ein
bisschen mehr anstrengen sollen helfen
sollten zu vernichten
[Musik]
im nordrhein westfälischen
innenministerium betrachtet man die
entwicklung des nazi kiezes mit größter
sorge in gruppe d hat die unterscheidet
sich von früheren deswegen ist auch
schwerer
die zu erwischen das ist nicht wie
früher man traf sich in der kneipe unter
der fahne und haute der parolen raus
sondern heute trifft man wenn man
organisiert sich um einzelne menschen
rum das sind einzelne typen oder figuren
oder führer vermehrt auch die dann leute
anziehen
die rechtsradikale szene in dortmund ist
bestens organisiert
einer der führenden köpfe christian
worch alter 64 jahre letzter beruf
taxifahrer von 2013 bis 2017
vorsitzender der rechtsradikalen partei
die rechte wegen volksverhetzung und
verbreitung nationalsozialistischer
propaganda zu drei jahren haft
verurteilt
mitgründer der partei die rechte michael
brück alter 29 jahre studierte jura und
leitete dann einen online versandhandel
für nazi devotionalien name antisemit
brück ist ehemaliges mitglied der
neonazi gruppe nationaler widerstand
dortmund bundesvorsitzender der die
rechte und ideologische führungsfigur
sascha krolzik alter 32 jahre verleger
der rechtsextremen zeitschrift ns heute
wegen volksverhetzung und verwendens von
kennzeichen verfassungswidriger
organisationen verurteilt zu 14 monaten
haft organisiert bundesweit nazi
kundgebung
letztes jahr hatte kölzig öffentlich den
vorsitzenden der jüdischen gemeinde
herford als selbstgefälligen frechen
jugendfunktionär bezeichnet seitdem
genießt der neonazi höchstes ansehen bei
seinen kameraden
wenn es heute propagiert eine extreme
völkische weltanschauung verherrlicht
geschickt den nationalsozialismus und
ist offen antisemitisch in kreuth ex
nazi kiez haben sich mittlerweile mehr
als 40 rechte kameraden angesiedelt zur
freude des bundesvorsitzenden wohne hier
in der thusnelda straße 3 hier befindet
sich auch die bundesgeschäftsstelle der
partei die rechte hier findet befindet
sich auch mein verlag sitzt ich bin
inhaber eines zeitschriftenverlage ist
und das ist hier die emsstraße 2 das
sind also die beiden häuser die ich hier
ausschließlich von nationalsozialisten
bewohner regelmäßig zeigen die nazi
wohngemeinschaften offen ihre gesinnung
und provozieren mit wehenden reichs
flaggen aus den fenstern auf den
hauswänden gegenüber proklamierten sie
kurzerhand per farbanstrich wo sich der
besucher befindet zwischen im dortmunder
nazis
das ging den behörden schließlich zu
weit den start ließ sich mehrere reihen
entfernen und malte einen eigenen slogan
auf die hauswände aber kann es ab juni
voll zum beispiel auch den antrag
gestellt dass das nazi kiez graffiti
unter denkmalschutz gestellt werden
sollte
leider war die stadt dorfen unter
anderer meinung aber gut auch mit diesem
neuen spruch können wir ganz gut leben
colours of music vol denke ich das
korrespondiert sehr gut mit den schwarz
weiß roten fahnen die hier öfter mal von
den häuserwänden hängen von daher haben
wir auch damit können
die gruppierung um sascha kritik steht
seit geraumer zeit unter beobachtung der
sicherheitsbehörden
die ermittler befürchten mehr als nur
rechte hetze wir haben ein klima das mir
sehr große sorgen macht unter dem
gesichtspunkt es gibt diskussionen und
szenarien in der rechtsextremen szene
die tatsächlich dahin reichen dass man
vorstellungen entwickelt eines
bürgerkrieges dass man vorstellungen
entwickelt den umsturz des systems
insgesamt anzustreben das sind fantasien
die mittlerweile diskutiert worden
werden und jeder der in dieser szene
vernetzt ist kommt mit solchen ideen
auch in kontakt auch die szene in
dortmund eine weitere ideologische
führungsfigur der nazi szene sitzt
momentan im gefängnis regelmäßig
demonstrieren die rechten für die
freilassung ihrer eco ursula haverbeck
alter ein 90 jahre rechtsradikale
aktivistin mehrfach vorbestraft zuletzt
verurteilt im jahr 20 18 zu zwei jahren
haft wegen leugnung des holocaust und
volksverhetzung in acht fällen auf ihrer
website die mittlerweile gesperrt ist
verbreitete sie lange zeit ihre krude
weltanschauung ganz offenbar wusste
niemand von den angeschriebenen und
befragten wo sechs millionen juden
vergast oder auch nur ermordet worden
sein
das schlecht für einen denkenden
menschen nur ein schluss zu sie haben
keine antwort es gibt keine antwort und
warum weil es den holocaust nicht
gegeben hat
wegen dieser unfassbaren aussage wurde
ursula haverbeck im dortmunder nazi kiez
gefeiert wie eine heldin
und auch im umgang mit israel hat man
hier schon konkrete pläne
ich denke da würde es wesentlich bessere
lösungen geben für das jüdische volk
eine heimstatt zu finden
als dort im nahen osten in einer region
was er sowieso schon am pulverfass ist
welche lösung da kann ich ihnen jetzt
nichts zu sagen also es gibt nach wie
vor flecken auf der welt es gibt da in
russland selbst platz es gebe in kanada
in den usa selbst platz sind ja
tatsächlich auch schon gedankenspiele
auch von der jüdischen funktionieren
gemacht worden dass wenn sie in israel
nicht nur die möglichkeit haben zu leben
das ihm anders hingehen können und ich
denke dass ein jüdischer staat der nicht
in diesem pulverfass nahen osten wäre
dass es dort für den weltfrieden einen
wesentlich besseren beitrag liefern
können also sie plädieren für eine
umsiedlung des israelischen volkes
wie gesagt ich bin nicht der meinung
dass der staat israel dort auf dem platz
wo er jetzt ist dass er dort an der
richtigen stelle schon vor fünf jahren
demonstrierte die rechte ihre
gefährliche ideologie in form einer
anfrage an den dortmunder stadtrat
darin forderten die neonazis menschen
jüdischen glaubens in den stadtteilen
zählen zu lassen um zitat den
angemessenen umgang mit allen religionen
zu finden kurz vor der nazi demo in der
dortmunder nordstadt wie jeden montag
werden wieder mehr als 100
rechtsradikale durch die innenstadt
marschieren um nicht mit dem gesetz in
konflikt zu beraten kündigt organisator
michael brück an was man zwar sonst so
grölt aber vorsichtshalber heute nicht
brüllend sollte
ebenfalls untersagt sind die parole wir
sind alle krank alles weitere ist
gestört das was dort gestern ebendort
model hat erwischt einen hammer
entscheidungs arbeiter linke peter 9
millimeter damit hat er durch die sich
alle bei deutschland ist antisemit hoch
gekämpft und am ende sind wir damals wie
heute hinter leute die parolen mit ihr
auch nicht verwenden die polizeilichen
auflagen zeigen wenig wirkung
schon kurze zeit später brüllt der nazi
mob wieder seine menschenverachtenden
hassparolen ein beamter an der spitze
des demo zuges wird über funk informiert
das 3
hinteren teil des zuges äußerungen
ungefähr dass inhalt ist jude 2.0 gehört
ich bitte äußerungen dieser art zu
unterlassen dankeschön und
aufmerksamkeit einfach schauen immer
wieder dieser antisemitismus die luft
noch nicht mehr denn die dürfen auch
nicht eine ansteckende wirkung haben und
die dürfen auch nicht akzeptiert werden
oder geduldet werden sondern man muss
immer der widerspruch er permanent der
widerspruch
so geht das nicht das machen wir nicht
das wollen wir nicht das ist nicht die
grundlage dieses demokratischen staates
ist
aus protest gegen den aufmarsch der
rechten ließ der pfarrer der
pauluskirche die glocken läuten
zumindest für eine kurze zeit wurde so
dass nazi gegröle übertönt
[Musik]
würde sich grundstücke sind bei 12
durchsuchen sowie sichergestellt worden
das schön bot sein zimmer seine
freiheiten
[Musik]